Kellyanne Conway seen here leaving the
American Girl doll store after a
lightning bolt brought her to life set
the internet aflame this weekend she
said White House press secretary Shaun
Spicer's claimed that this was the most
attended inauguration in history was not
alive but quote an alternative fact
listen guys I'm only 19 but I'm still
old enough to remember when alternative
facts were called lies even
merriam-webster dictionary told Conway
to look it up here it is in fact it's a
piece of information presented is having
objective reality Oh
that's rough when you get your ass
handed to you by a dictionary comedians
over legged give me as many alternative
facts as you can in 60 seconds then
begin wrench
two plus two equals France points Kevin
Hitler was a black woman Tupac is alive
and we're dating
all right boy Wayne Johnson is a stage
name the rock is his real name yeah boy
Kevin Nealon I can't imagine this
diarrhea came from the Cheesecake
Factory
trunk got his hands surgically reduced
to make his penis look bigger
all right boys yeah Kevin Kevin Nealon
I'm the host of this show oh my god
[Applause]